[Музика]
добре, хлопці, я радий бачити вас
тут, і ми продовжуємо говорити про
підтримку,
добре, тому пам’ятайте, що минулого разу ми просили вас
відповісти на кілька запитань, чи не могли б ви
перевірити разом з нами свої відповіді,
щоб перше
Світовий рекорд на 100 метрів – це правий 9,50 8 секунд
на більшості легкоатлетичних доріжок один круг
– правильний. Легкі змагання на 800 метрів, які
включають стрибки та метання, є більш холодними
заповненими праворуч, ніж подія, яка
складається з 10 легкоатлетичних змагань,
називається da right  десятиборство в
Олімпійських іграх 2004 року проходили в Афінах,
і останнє питання нашої вікторини предмет,
який передається бігуну Тирана в
естафеті, називається естафетою, тому
вітаю тих дітей, які
правильно виконали цю вікторину, і ми продовжуємо
наш урок, тому  перше завдання полягає в тому, щоб
ви розблокували обидва слова на джамбо,
тобто розставити літери в правильних місцях,
щоб ви могли вгадати перше слово, хм, що
може бути правильно,
що це стадіон незалежно від того  якщо одна
зустріч, звичайно,
це команда, а наступна хм, Атліт,
ти маєш рацію, наступний, і
це тренер, дуже важлива людина, добре,
хм, довгий,
і це конкурент, наступне місце,
хм, цікаве, правильно
, це конкурс  один хм, звичайно,
це поразка
і правильна Ліга добре, останнє,
ви цілком праві
, це сезон, тому ось слова,
які ви повинні використовувати під час своїх уроків
спорт з м'ячем, тому ще раз стадіон команда
спортсмен тренер конкурент змагання поразка
ліга та сезон давайте  рухайся далі, тож сьогодні
ми будемо виконувати завдання на аудіювання, і
перш ніж ми почнемо слухати, я б хотів, щоб
ви поглянули на ці картинки та
слова,
так що у вас тут є дартс-
паби, гольф-клуб, який ми робимо і кефаль
подивіться на фотографії та скажіть мені, що
таке дартс, яке зображення це правильно,
це дартс дуже відома гра, в яку грали
в Англії okay bubs bubs хм, я думаю,
що це місце, тому яке зображення відповідає
цьому слову саме це, тому паб є
місце whe  люди грають у дартс і добре проводять
час під час своїх вечорів,
тоді настає гольф-клуб Golf Club – це
те, що вам потрібно використовувати, щоб грати в гольф,
добре, і ще два незвичайних слова, які ми скорочуємо
і кефалі, тому ми ріжемо правильно, це
зло, і ви можете знайти  цей об'єкт у
крикеті, а останній — кефаль
, це молот, яким ви граєте в поло,
коли їдете верхи, хлопці, так
що ви готові виконати завдання на аудіювання, тому
вашій увазі на екрані
ви повинні підкреслити спорт  ви
чуєте, слухаючи, перегляньте
список у вас є їхній дартс футбол
гольф бейсбол регбі автоперегони снукер
плавання велоспорт аеробіка та баскетбол
буде згадано багато видів спорту, але не всі види спорту, які
ви повинні підкреслити добре
, ви готові слухати, тож почнемо
добре, англійці вважаються
твердими та флегматичними, правда чи ні, їхні
традиційні види спорту досить повільні та
невимушені. Хорошим прикладом такого
виду спорту є дартс, популярна гра, в яку грають у
пабах, у яких коротка сталь  дартс
кидають у круглу дошку
з метою набрати певну
кількість очок, оскільки долари популярні
серед робітничого класу. У гольф грають
вищі класи, це стара шотландська
гра для двох або чотирьох осіб, які б'ють
маленькі жорсткі м'ячі  зі спеціальними клюшками для гольфу
на 9 або 18 лунок на гірському
майданчику, який називається полем для гольфу,
крикет ще більш витончений. Гравці в
крикет зазвичай є чоловіками,
традиційно одягненими в білий одяг. У
гру грають дві команди по 11 осіб
на місячному трав'яному полі зі спеціальними ваннами
та
хвіртки Англійці також люблять снукер, дуже
схожий на більярд і м'ячі. Гра, в
якій катається важкий дерев'яний м'яч,
ми одні так, що він зупиняється
якомога ближче до маленького білого
м'яча іншим британським видом спорту є поло,
призначене для гравців.  елітна гра з м’ячем, у яку
грають верхи на коні з кефальами,
згадані вище види спорту можна
вважати типовими британськими, але це
не означає, що вони є
найпопулярнішими.  переважна більшість
британців займаються індивідуальними
видами спорту, такими як плавання, їзда на велосипеді, риболовля,
аеробіка або просто ходьба, однак лише
10% дорослих регулярно займаються спортом,
інші вважають за краще дивитися по телевізору
улюблені види спорту для глядачів —
футбол національна гра, регбі, легка атлетика та
теніс, добре, тому слухайте  до тексту
вперше чи готові ви
сказати відповіді та підкреслити вид спорту, який ви
чуєте добре, тож правильні відповіді –
дартс футбол гольф регбі снукер
плавання велоспорт аеробіка всі інші
види спорту не згадувалися в The
Listening добре, хлопці, ви готові
слухати  вже вдруге вам
доведеться послухати ще раз, і ви повинні
зробити свій вибір і відповісти на
запитання, які ви бачите на екрані, ви можете
мати три-дві хвилини, щоб
переглянути запитання, які у нас є, тому я
сподіваюся, що все в порядку  ясно і
немає невідомих слів для вас добре, тому
є шість питань, послухайте і
виберіть правильні відповіді,
тому давайте послухаємо ще раз  Англійці
вважаються твердими та флегматичними,
правда, чи ні, їхні традиційні спори
досить повільні та невимушені. Хорошим
прикладом такого виду спорту є дартс,
популярна гра, в яку грають у пабах, де
впевнені сталеві двері кидають на
дошку з метою  набираючи
певну кількість очок, оскільки двері
популярні серед робітничого класу. У
гольф грають вищі класи.
Це стара шотландська гра для двох або чотирьох
осіб, які б'ють маленькі тверді м'ячі
спеціальними клюшками для гольфу в 9 або 18 лунок
на полі  називається полем для гольфу
крикет ще більш витончений гравці в
крикет, як правило, люди, традиційно
одягнені в білий одяг. У гру
грають дві команди по 11 осіб на трав'яному
полі зі спеціальними ваннами і хвіртками.
Англійці також люблять снукер,
схожість з більярдом і м'ячами.  Гра,
в якій важкий дерев'яний м'яч
перекочується поодинці таким чином, щоб він зупинився
якомога ближче до маленького білого
м'яча іншим британським видом спорту є поло.
для еліти гра в чашу, в яку
грають верхи на конях з
кефальами, згаданий вище вид спорту може
вважатися типово британським, але це
не означає, що вони є
найпопулярнішими. Переважна більшість
британців бере участь в індивідуальних
видах спорту, таких як плавання, їзда на велосипеді, риболовля
аеробіка або просто ходьба, однак лише
10% дорослих регулярно займаються спортом
інші вважають за краще дивитися телевізор
улюблені види спорту для глядачів
футбол національна гра регбі легка атлетика та
теніс не поспішайте та позначте
відповіді привіт, коли будете готові, ми можемо
почати,
тому першим  питання, як ви можете
охарактеризувати британські традиційні види спорту,
привіт і, судячи з прослуховування,
вони повільні та невимушені, добре, а як
щодо другого питання, яка гра дуже
популярна в пабах, чи, звичайно, гра
- це дартс, третя, яка
гра крикет легка складна  людина, яка
хоче грати
інші індивідуальні види спорту популярні у
Великій Британії, і це снукер і
м'ячі, тоді скільки англійців
регулярно займаються спортом і кількість
становить 10% лише 10% британців
регулярно займаються ним
що з Україною ми займаємося спортом
регулярно добре давайте відповімо на
питання після прослуховування, тому
перше, які види спорту також популярні
в Україні, подумайте трохи особисто я
думаю, що футбол баскетбол і
теніс також популярні в Україні, але,
на жаль, крикет поло чи регбі
не такі популярні в Україні добре
друге запитання, якщо ви мали  можливість
спробувати будь-який, який би ви вибрали,
подумайте,
якби у мене була можливість, я б, напевно,
вибрав Пауло, я люблю коней, і я думаю, що
хотів би спробувати грати в поло, і
останнє запитання, що ви більше хочете
дивитися або брати участь для мене  відповідь
очевидна, я однозначно вважаю за краще брати
участь, але мені подобається дивитися фігурне
катання, наприклад, ми готові рухатися
далі, хлопці, як ви коли-небудь робите таке
фразові фразові дієслова добре ви знаєте, що
є частини мови, і ви знаєте,
що є дієслова, але що таке
фразові дієслова фразові дієслова - це дієслова,
які складаються з двох трьох або більше частин,
вони складаються з правильного дієслова, а
дуже звичайне дієслово, наприклад go  або приєднатися або
взяти, а потім ми додаємо прийменник
і весь зміст змінюється давайте подивимося
на фразові дієслова, пов'язані
з темою спорту, тож перший
продовжуй,
то що означає продовжувати я знаю
Керрі
я знаю свою, але разом  сенс полягає в тому,
щоб продовжувати добре продовжувати біг підтюпцем
продовжуй кататися продовжуй читати давайте
продовжимо добре, другий це все,
але вихід до цього означає поїсти
в ресторані, це не вдома, добре,
наступний здавайся, я чув  ця фраза, яку
вони кажуть, ніколи не здавайся і здаватися
означає перестати робити те, що ти
робиш регулярно, тому ніколи не відмовляйся від спорту.
прийди і
пограй зі мною, будь зі мною видалений, щоб вилучити
суддя або суддя може зробити це, тому це
означає, що гравець залишив гру,
наприклад гравець номер 11 був
видалений, це означає, що він більше не гратиме
під час цього матчу  або вся
ліга наступна займіться займіться що
це означає, що це означає почати хобі чи
спорт
Я думаю зайнятися новим видом спорту,
можливо, бокс наступний відмовляється,
коли музика занадто голосна, і ви можете  Не
чуєш нікого, тобі потрібно зменшити свою
музику, а остання включена, коли
ти не чуєш, тобі потрібно
збільшити гучність William, тому збільшити гучність означає збільшити гучність добре, ти
готовий зробити щось  вправи на фразові
дієслова, тож перше, ви повинні зайнятися
спортом, тоді ви отримаєте більше вправ,
тож і ви піднялися вгору і вниз,
який би ви вибрали, візьміть це
правильно, другий я намагаюся працювати,
будь ласка, будь ласка  увімкніть свою музику, вона
занадто голосна, щоб зменшити вашу музику
і наступне  Один просто запитайте, і я впевнений,
що інші діти дозволять вам
приєднатися, інші діти дозволять вам
брати участь в їхніх іграх, тоді
один рефері послав Девіда за те, що
він посварився з ним, тому Девід був вилучений, і
це правильна відповідь.  остання,
це моя улюблена пісня, поверніть її вправо,
увімкніть її
добре, хлопці, добре попрацюйте з фразовими
дієсловами, ще одне завдання, і ви майже
закінчили, тож наступне - ідіоми, у нас
тут різні спори, тому у вас є
бокс  плавання ігри з м'ячем і
крикет дуже часто люди створюють
дуже цікаві фрази, використовуючи свій
досвід, вони можуть звучати цікаво,
і вони можуть означати також цікаві
речі, тому з боксом пов'язана ідіома,
подивіться
Saved by the Bell, то що
означає бути  Врятований дзвоном, щоб бути
врятованим дзвоном,
це означає, що ви несподівано врятовані
від дуже поганої ситуації, в якій ви опинилися
, подивіться на приклад, який я
збирався дати вам тест з математики, але вас
врятував дзвін
Урок закінчився наступна область
пов'язана з плаванням або плаванням
або плаванням, це дуже цікава
ситуація, дуже часто ми можемо опинитися в такій
ситуації, що маємо або виграти, або
потерпіти невдачу, подивіться на приклад, у якому ми
знаходимося  Ситуація тонути або плавати, це означає, що
ми маємо або виграти, або потерпіти невдачу, немає інших
варіантів, тоді в іграх з м’ячем також є
кілька ідіом: м’яч на вашому
майданчику,
коли граєте в теніс, м’яч
на вашому місці на вашому майданчику,
це означає, що це ваше  час дати
відповідь, подивіться на приклад, щоб
ви отримали відповідь від тренера
м'ячі на вашому майданчику, а тепер що ви
збираєтеся їй сказати,
наступна ідіома пов'язана з крикетом,
тому подивіться, будьте на липучці  wicket
sticky щось липке може бути солодким і
тому липке, то це означає, що ви
не в дуже приємній ситуації, і
ця ситуація може викликати у вас певні
неприємності або проблеми, подивіться на цей
приклад, він на липучій хвіртці
з результатами тесту, тому його  результати тесту  s може
знову спричинити йому деякі проблеми. Врятований
у колокола
раковини або плавання, м'яч у вашому майданчику
і будьте на хвіртці, хлопці,
м'яч на вашому майданчику, і ми підготували
для вас виклик,
чи не вживайте ви, будь ласка, ці фразові дієслова
ви  дивіться на екрані, наприклад, продовжуйте
, відмовтеся, приєднайтеся до піску, візьміть угору,
поверніть вниз або поверніть і ідіоми, які ви
бачили на попередньому слайді, щоб скласти
свою історію, і не могли б ви опублікувати це
в командах цього уроку
I'  Буду дуже чекати на ваші відповіді,
і я постараюся прочитати їх усі та
відповісти на них, тому будьте моїм гостем і надішліть мені
історію, побачимось наступного разу, було дуже
приємно працювати з вами сьогодні, до побачення
[Музика]